well i think i get a bit paranoid that
that might kill it for me if i
if it looks too much like a proper job
thank you for joining us alice now
you've found success across
three different mediums of storytelling
there's a lot to cover
but i wonder if first we could go back
um
to how it started when did you get into
writing and become interested in theater
um i mean i i
consider myself very lucky i think i
always knew i wanted to be a writer
i don't think i knew that you could
write i don't think i understood that
you could write scripts or like plays or
films you know or like what what people
said on when you turned on your telly
had been written by somebody but um
i always sort of wrote stories when i
was younger and then
they did sort of come out like plays
accidentally i guess my parents parents
sort of took us to the panto when i was
quite little and that was just the most
thrilling
thing and i wrote a panto when i was
about seven or eight made my friends
yeah
which is horrible
and um
and then
yeah i just um
and then i think you know my we didn't
we lived in quite a small town but that
didn't really have theater or anything
but my mum was really great at kind of
like seeing seeing that that was that
was something that i loved and so so
would take us um
and then
yeah when i was 16 i did work experience
at the war court theatre in london
which was really i mean i wrote them
several begging letters um
and and then they kind of let me come
for a week and that was a huge
kind of game changer really because i
just i read all these plays by writers
i'd never heard of before and um
and
and and then from then on i think that
was like okay that's that's what i want
to do so i yeah it was it was always
what i wanted to do
and then what was your first break then
as a playwright
um
i mean it was it
it felt like that you know it felt like
i'd made up my mind quite quickly and no
no then it took a little bit longer you
know wrote a play at university that i
had lots of cups of tea on you know like
i sort of my tutor sent it to david
eldridge who's the playwright and he and
he was really kind and gave me lots of
sort of advice and i got an agent um but
nothing happens you know i was i had
done a group with polly stenham who's a
brilliant playwright who had written a
play at age 19 and it had gone on and
was you know great big big hit um
and i think i was like right so that'll
be that's how you do it and and it just
didn't happen so i sort of had um
you know wrote lots of short plays that
were on in you know pub theaters and you
know sort of
yeah i did did that for what felt like
quite a long time and then i wrote
a play called many moons which was on a
theater above a pub which which did okay
and it was published and but i had you
know other jobs and was sort of writing
in between waitressing shifts and
nannying and um
and i guess there was a shift i wrote a
play for the rsc
um
which was called revolt she said revolt
again and and i think that one sort of
just got a little bit more attention and
so i had some meetings from that and
then i met
through that play i i sort of met the
director
will oldroyd who
said you know he who he was a filmmaker
and he wanted to make his first feature
and i wasn't really interested in film i
sort of hadn't really
you know i really loved watching films
and that just felt like it was this
whole other it was sort of like being
like and now why don't you come and
sort of be a scientist you know it just
felt like a whole other um skill set and
and um
so i think i was a bit not sure but i
really liked him and and found him
really inspiring and thought we could
you know and he'd made some really
interesting strains beautiful short
films um
and um
yeah we sort of hung out a bit and then
i i had read this book at university
which is one of maybe only three times
i've had this
where i thought oh i think this would
make a great film
and that book was um uh lady macbeth of
the 10th which is this russian novella
by nikolai leskov and i i gave it to
will and he really loved it so
we began that process through eye
features
and
yeah so so sort of went through that
whole scheme and um and and
ended up making that film which was
a really brilliant experience and like
what's the difference do you think from
writing a play
you know for the stage versus you know
your debut um feature film
yeah i mean
i was so lucky on lady macbeth because
we didn't i
we really i mean we had lots of support
and eye features you know that scheme
they really sort of nurture you and
and give you sort of lessons and
everything and so that was great so i
really sort of felt like i was getting
you know lots of lots of support because
it felt quite daunting to write a film
script you know i didn't like even final
draft is like
yeah it's quite a thing to kind of
grapple with i just couldn't i just
couldn't figure out before in fact i
wrote it like a play script for a long
time until they were like me you have to
have to do it in final draft at some
point so um
and it was i hadn't done an adaptation
on on stage either but at that point
and um and
and so it just it felt like a whole kind
of different thing i mean
theater certainly in this country
theater's really
i have found um
broadly speaking to be to be sort of the
writer is really
it's it's you know it's all about your
voice and and sort of um
and and you can i suppose feel like the
primary
author and creator in that sense whereas
film and tv is it has felt slightly
different um
at various points so
but in terms of the writing
essentially it's still the same thing i
still feel like it's me on my own trying
to like pull something from me
you know usually in the middle of the
night
yeah
and then did you miss that did you miss
that sort of autonomy you know that you
described when you're a playwright
versus when you're collaborating in such
a different way on a film
i mean
i i i like to work on more than one
thing at the same time so i think i i
think i do sort of need to feel like i
that like those different muscles are
being used and and that
you know maybe
maybe i can you know my ego can be fed
more in theater
and then but i you know when you're
working with the right people
i find that kind of collaboration really
brilliant i sort of found with lady
macbeth
that i wanted to write a really robust
map for will so that when he was on set
he could he had something that felt very
like
i you know i did all the sort of
character work that i would normally do
and sort of and and just be really
rigorous and um and just make sure that
there was a real sort of a really strong
foundation for him to stand on so that
those conversations that sometimes
happen on set with an actor
you know where they want to try a
different line or suddenly they have a
different idea or the shot does
something else or it's raining that day
whatever it is that you can sort of be a
bit more
you know if you if you've done all that
groundwork then then hopefully you're
you've just sort of had the freedom to
to do what's needed on the on the day in
that moment but i
yeah i mean it's also
i think it's just it is really lovely to
kind of hand something over as well to
somebody else that you trust and feel
inspired by it was
yeah
and now going on to your
tv work um
so i think your first tv experience was
working as the story editor on
succession
um can you talk a little bit about that
time um in the writers room and
i wonder if
you draw on some of those kind of
lessons that you absorbed in that room
when you're
writing your own tv shows now
for sure yeah that was i mean
i was such a fan of as i worked on the
second series and um
and just thought the first series was
like incredible and just loved it and i
had met jesse a few years before and um
and jesse armstrong who who's the
creator and um show right now and um he
yeah just asked if i'd like to come and
be in the room and i had never been in a
writer's room before it's sort of you
know i think i think there's loads more
now in this country but it's sort of you
know it feels like such an american
tradition and
i was really
i had sort of started just was just
starting kind of work on
my own show that i was you know gonna be
show runner on so i sort of thought well
this would be such a wonderful
opportunity to come and kind of see what
that's like and and be be in someone
else's process um
and succession is
you know the rice room is really it goes
on really long time which is a real
luxury um and um
but i think you can just feel it in the
show those characters are so
you know you could we spend like such a
long time talking about how long how
long are you talking like
what
months yeah yeah they had already done
some work in the summer some other
writers and sort of like on the broader
kind of plot arc and then and then you
know you spend a week on each episode
and then you go back again and it just
it
i mean there is of course there's
pressure and by the end of it you're
still feeling like there's a lot of
pressure but you do also really feel
like you have time to kind of talk about
he's incredible and there's so much
in that show that
never makes it onto screening a in a
like explicit way but it's just so baked
into those characters and he knows you
know their whole history and everything
that they've ever said to each other and
you know it's sort of and i think you
can really feel that so it just
it felt like
i mean it was it was such a thrill to be
in that room and and it's very funny
like you know there's sort of um
and um
yeah i mean i just i absolutely stole
like all of history
i sort of just i really took it as a
real opportunity to learn and he's
incredibly generous about about that
when you went on to
adapt normal people and obviously that
was a phenomenal success i loved it um
were you so how did that come up come up
were you a fan of sally's work um
and was it a daunting prospect to adapt
this source material
yes yes yes yes and yes yes
um uh
yeah i had read the book um
when it came out i thought
um i'd read it really quickly i am i was
and i was i had quite a young child at
the time he wasn't really sleeping and i
really remember sort of like sitting on
his bedroom floor
just reading it even though i should
have been asleep
um because he was finally asleep and um
uh
yeah i just it felt like such an
emotional experience to read i saw
hoovered it and it was really compelling
and
i fell in love with those characters and
you know it's such a she's such an
elegant writer
and i i think i i think this is the only
time i've done this so i emailed my
agent straight away and i was like
what's happening who's doing this can i
be you know like can
i would love to work on this is there
any kind of way and then
he said oh it's you know it's that lenny
abramson's doing it and um it's with
rose go on it bbc and um and and sally
rooney is writing it and i was just
saying okay well that's i'm just gonna
wait that sounds heaven
um
and then
a few months later
they got in touch because
sally had written the first six
and
done the most beautiful job like you
know that i read those scripts and they
were just in you know the dialogue was
just beautiful and it was really like
the experience of reading the book um
but i think she wanted to work on her
next book and was in the middle of this
press you know tour for
because of course normal people the book
was just the most phenomenal
success so
they asked if i would come and come and
kind of work work on it so i
uh i co-wrote i did the next pass on the
on the first six but we you know we kept
working together
and then i did the next four and the
last one
um
so i mean it was such a
i was i was quite busy when that when
they called but i just was like yeah of
course i would love to do this that such
a as it was a dream dream job um
and
yes incredible i mean was it it was it
was daunting when i
if i would let myself think about what
it was but i
i think i'm quite a
compartmentalizer and i do tend to
forget that there's going to be an
audience or that or that anyone else has
read that book i tried really
hard to
just remember how i felt when i read it
and i said can you go through your
process of adapting a novel how do you
identify
something to adapt um
so i know normal people caught your eye
because you were a reader of it a
genuine fan
so yeah is that how is that how it it
comes about quite naturally to you
no it's it's different every time and um
i mean i suppose first yeah i sort of
felt
lucky in a really lucky
incredibly fortunate position where
people will send me books or articles or
you know things to
to to read or or even you know i've just
done this just finishing this tv show
that's an adaptation of a film from the
80s so it's
you know it's um
i think it's again it's just back to
those
the guts the light instincts you know we
read something and it might not be
this is the best thing ever written or
or or it's but it's but there's
something about it i just i just sort of
feel like i know
i can see it there's a reason to adapt
it i understand that you know it will
that it will kind of
as it transitions it will
it makes sense that it needs it could it
could exist in a new form
in a new medium
on a screen whether it's a film or a tv
um series and it's it's really really
different every time it's often about a
character and like you know do i feel
compelled and excited to spend
a lot of time
with these people and
and tell these stories and and just does
it feel cinematic or does it feel
compelling or does it feel
funny or does this feel like something i
haven't seen before like something i
suppose is this something that can like
really hold my interest and something
that i can kind of fall in love with and
grapple with for like
maybe years because sometimes it is
often it's yes
um
and then
i mean
i didn't do with this with normal people
so maybe i shouldn't do it because
because that won't work but i do tend to
if it's a book i tend to write it out by
hand that's what's like the first thing
i'll do
purely because that's like a really
practical thing to do and often
my first feeling after having said yes
to something or day one on a new project
is a bit like oh god what
what should i do i've forgotten what my
job is and so to have quite a practical
task um
i find really helpful
and i think it also
there's something about that process
that means
i probably
i'll i'll definitely find things that i
missed on the first or second read
always yeah
and i think it gives me a kind of like
you have to find a way to take ownership
over it
and and that sometimes is helpful
because psychologically maybe i'm
pretending
[Music]
i'd love to talk about
what a writing day looks like for you um
so what's a typical day like when you're
working
what's your space like um what do you
need around you to work
yeah and it's i think it's there are
some things that have really changed
some things that have really changed and
some things that have remained pretty
much the same i'm not
i don't i think it's wonderful when
writers so and i think it's really
important to say that when
when
when there is a rhythm or a process or
i know lots of writers you know you have
to sort of have
you know it start the day starts at nine
and you do this and then you do this and
then you do this and or you have to hit
five thousand words or whatever it is
and i think i think those are great i'm
um
i've never been able to kind of find a
grown-up way of doing it and i i think
that's probably
something uh that i don't i think i get
a bit paranoid that that might kill it
for me if i
if it looks too much like a proper job
um i write like when i'm writing scripts
or
um plays or whatever i tend to do
the best work or the most of it at night
so i'll
do a you know when it's coming up to a
deadline i'll i'll do a series of
all-nighters and and you know sort of
start when the kids have gone to bed and
i've
exhausted the internet or whatever and
you know if it's going well then
two three four five in the morning and
and
because there's something about it that
i think feels
quite private that time of day i feel
quite far away from
the idea that anyone's gonna see it or
read it so i feel like i can be a bit
braver
um
and and and also i think since having
kids i think it's sort of yeah it kind
of gets me a bit further away from them
sometimes which is sometimes necessary
and so a lot of our audience i think
will be you know emerging writers and um
[Music]
one of the sort of parts of our jobs if
you like is dealing with notes and
dealing with rejection yeah so
what advice would you have uh for people
that are listening
yeah i mean again i think that be kind
to yourself i think thing is really
important
um
you know and and you do so like do you
trust that you that it gets
better and and
you know that you will develop more
tools and be more equipped to kind of
to deal with both of those things and
that they happen in different ways you
know they're sort of like i still turn
in a draft and
and get heaps of notes or and or it
feels like a rejection and you know
you've got more work to do than you
thought or
um and it's still painful but you you
sort of
i don't know i think it sort of feels
more pragmatic as well um
i think
i mean
it is unfortunately part of it the
rejection and and
and i do
you know i suppose
i it's really easy for me to say this
now i appreciate but i am forever
grateful that that first play that i
wrote on the young writers program did
not have the experience that polly
stellen had it didn't go on immediately
and have lots of people staring at it
because i wasn't ready
and and i got to like
i got to make mistakes in safer
environments and i got to try things out
and i got to like really find my voice
in in a whole kind of different
you know i would say like find work
really hard to find your community and
like go and
see as much stuff as possible and read
as much as possible and like read stuff
that you don't like and watch stuff that
you don't like and
also
like you know think about it as
like art like go and you know go and
stand in the gallery and think about
like look at a picture and think about
your work being part of that like i
think it's i i think it's important to
take it seriously whilst not taking
yourself too seriously
you